Melanie Klein was a highly creative and
original Viennese Jewish psychoanalyst
who discovered the work of Freud at the
age of 32 and devoted her life to
enriching and nuancing it in intriguing
and valuable ways born in 1882 Klein was
held back by her father from her desire
to become a doctor and was pushed by her
family into a loveless marriage with a
coarse unpleasant man with whom she had
nothing in common she was bored sexually
frustrated and mentally unwell
psychoanalysis saved her she left her
husband read everything she could
attended lectures and started publishing
papers of her own she soon departed from
Freud in an area that most other
analysts had overlooked the analysis of
children Freud had been very skeptical
that children could ever be analyzed
properly their minds being in his view
too unformed to allow for a perspective
on the unconscious but Klein now argued
that an analyst could get a useable view
into a child in a world through studying
how they played with toys she therefore
equipped her consulting room with small
horses figurines and locomotives and
established herself as a child
psychoanalyst first in Berlin and then
in London where she settled in 1926 and
remained for the rest of her life in her
work with children Melanie Klein wanted
to understand how human beings evolved
from the primitive pleasure-seeking
impulses of early infancy to the more
mature adaptations of later life and in
particular she wanted to know what might
go wrong on this journey giving rise to
the neurotic adaptations of adults in
her 1932 book the psychoanalysis of
children she described the difficulty of
the young infant situation weak utterly
at the mercy of adults unable to grasp
what's happening the infant cannot in
Klein's description grasp that people
around it are in fact people with their
own alternative reality in independent
points of view in the early weeks the
mother is not even a mother to her child
she is to come to the crux of Melanie
Klein's theories just a pair of breasts
which appear and disappear with
unpredictable and painful randomness in
relation to this mother all the infant
experiences are moments of intense pain
and then equally intense pleasure when
the breast is there in the milk flows a
primordial calm and satisfaction
descends upon the infant it's suffused
with feelings of well-being gratitude
and tenderness feelings that will in
adulthood be strongly associated with
being in love a moment where breasts
continue to play a notable role for many
but when the breast is for whatever
reason missing the infant feels starving
enraged terrified and vengeful this
thought Klein leads the infant to adopt
a primitive defense mechanism against
what would otherwise be intolerable
anxiety the infant splits the mother
into two very different breasts a good
breast and a bad breast the bad breast
is hated with a passion the infant wants
to bite wound and destroy this object of
unholy frustration but the good breast
is revered with an equally thorough
their more benign intensity with time in
healthy development this split heals the
child gradually perceives that there is
in truth no entirely good and no
entirely bad breast both belong to a
mother who is a perplexing mixture of
the positive and the negative a source
of pleasure and frustration joy and
suffering the child discovers a key idea
in kleinian psychoanalysis the concept
of ambivalence to be able to feel
ambivalent about someone is for Klein
Ian's and enormous psychological
achievement and the first marker on the
path to genuine maturity but it isn't
inevitable or assured only slowly can a
healthy child grasp the crucial
distinction between intention and effect
between what a mother may have wanted
for it and what the child may have felt
at her hands nevertheless these
complicated psychological reactions
belong to a phase that Klein called the
depressive position a moment of
soberness and melancholy when the
growing child takes on board
unconsciously the idea that reality is
more complicated and less morally meet
than it had ever previously imagined the
mother and other people generally cannot
neatly be blamed for every setback
almost nothing is totally pure or
totally evil things are a perplexing
thought-provoking mixture of the good
and the bad
this is hard to take and for Klein
explains the serious faraway look that
may sometimes enter the eyes of children
during daydreams these small beings look
oddly wise and grave at such moments
they are somewhere deep inside cotton
anon to the moral ambiguity of the real
adult world
unfortunately in Klein's analysis not
everyone makes it to the depressive
position some get stuck in a mode of
primitive splitting that she termed the
paranoid schizoid position for many
years even into adulthood these
unfortunate people find themselves
unable to tolerate the slightest
ambivalence they're keen to preserve the
sense of their own innocence and they
must either hate or love they seek
scapegoats or they idealize in
relationships they fall violently in
love and then at some inevitable moment
when a lover in some way disappoints
them they switch abruptly and become
incapable of feeling anything anymore
these unfortunates are likely to move
from candidate to candidate always
seeking a vision of complete
satisfaction total goodness which is
repeatedly violated by an unwitting
error on the lovers part we don't have
to believe in the literal truth of every
part of Melanie Klein's theories to see
that they have value for us as an
unusual but useful representation of
what it means to be a proper grown-up
the impulse to reduce people into what
they can do for us give us milk make us
money keep us happy rather than what
they are in and of themselves in other
words a multifaceted being this can be
painfully observed in emotional life
generally with Melanie Klein's help we
learn that coming to terms with the
ambivalent complex nature of all
relationships belongs to the business of
growing up a task we're never quite done
with and is likely to leave us a little
sad if not for a time quite simply
depressed
you